I don't teach killer shots what do you
teach them defense defenses for [ __ ]
[Music]
we're survivors
show me
[Music]
sword-fighting breaking things I hope I
haven't broken this place seems like
there's a lot of drama around here it
has nothing to do with you
it was an active night I didn't handle
it so well I've been there things get
hectic in my life and I fight happens to
the best of us were the worst
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
finally got our first look at the actual
Nightwing costume on Titan soil
breakdown what's going on there's a new
round of that DC giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your best Nightwing Theory on the
video they're still filming episodes for
this season of Titans and it looks like
he's already gotten the costume as of
mid season based on the logo in the look
of the costume it looks like they're
going on a version of the rebirth
costume which i think is great
all the Nightwing costumes are good
still wondering if they're gonna have
the disco Nightwing costume from back in
the classic Teen Titans comics we'll
have to wait and see about that quick
recap if you haven't been watching
Titans this season season 2 has been
doing actual genuine Teen Titans comic
book stuff it feels way more authentic
to what you think a Teen Titans series
should be season 1 of titans started
after Dick Grayson had been away from
Batman for a couple years
he incorrectly assumed that Batman was
trying to turn him into a weapon so he
left and he went to Detroit to be a
police officer like Nightwing was a
police officer in the comics during the
Chuck Dixon era during that period he
kept the Robin costume and when he
couldn't help people during the day as a
police officer he would help them at
night as a vigilante beating up
criminals that were going after children
the Titans start to come together he
encounters the new Robin the Batman has
taken that he did not know about he
actually finds out about it for the
first time when the new Robin Jason Todd
shows up just like Jason Todd was the
second version of Robin in the comics
most of Jason Todd's arc is about
setting up that Red Hood storyline but
while they're talking about what it was
like for him to be Robin for Dick
Grayson they start talking about new
costumes and then later when Donna Troy
enters the series she starts talking
about Dick Grayson adopting a new
persona but he thinks that the world
wants him to become Batman and even
though he did become Batman in the
comics for a while Donna Troy tells him
don't be Batman be someone else and they
just sort of leave it hanging like okay
we're just waiting for someone to say
Nightwing he burns the Robin costume and
now at the beginning of season 2 there
at the Titans tower going full-blown
Teen Titans from the comics but after
the first couple of episodes they still
have not mentioned the Nightwing name
and he hasn't given any indication that
he's building a new suit or asking
Batman to help him make a new suit you
need to set the tone I'm not robbing
anymore you are
heywait farm Robin who are you it's a
good question he and Jason Todd had this
whole thing during season one where they
talk about the special Xylon fiber
material that their suits are made of
that Batman's suit is made of so they're
just hyping up that Batman is going to
help him make a special new suit what's
going on right now is that dr. light has
teamed up with Deathstroke Deathstroke
is really coming for them it's all about
his plan and setting out the Judas
contract storyline that's where the
Ravager comes in she sort of the Tara of
this version of the Judas contract story
Deathstroke frees dr. light from prison
and sets in to the task of just
harassing the Titans as much as possible
like you see in that clip they have
history together because the classic
Titans took him down and the reason why
he wound up in prison for the last five
years but Deathstroke is trying to pick
the Titans off one at a time Jason Todd
just happens to be the most recent
person that he's going after so that's
where we get to Judas contract storyline
in the Nightwing origin story because
these pictures are from the last couple
of episodes it looks like they haven't
quite got to any real big turns because
you see ravager in her full-on comic
book Ravager uniform I think it's great
that they're going for that as of right
now she's being really standoffish
she hasn't formed any kind of bond with
the Titans yet but she's super intense
just like Jason Todd but that's why I'm
saying that she is sort of the terror of
this version of the Judas contract and
she'll form a relationship with Jason
Todd so he'll sort of be the Beast Boy
of this version of Judas contract and
you can kind of assume where they'll
take things from there they really want
you to think the Deathstroke is going to
wind up killing Jason Todd but here's
the thing about the Dick Grayson
character becoming Nightwing there are a
couple things about his origin story
that they haven't set up on the show yet
like the reason why he chose the name
Nightwing if you're not a big comic book
reader the very first time that he took
the name Nightwing in debuted his new
costume the disco Nightwing costume was
during tales of the Teen Titans
during the Judas contract storyline back
in 1984 but here's the thing he got the
inspiration for the Nightwing name from
Superman who we have not seen on the
Titans TV show yet although during
season two episode one
Dick Grayson mentioned sin when Beast
Boy is asking if he's gonna get to meet
Batman you're used to it life's a lot
better with
sounds like something Batman would say
do we get immune this time no Superman
seriously no the whole reason why
Superman is the inspiration for the
Nightwing name is because originally the
Nightwing character debuted in 1963 in
an issue of Superman called invasion of
the super people it's a bottle city of
Kandor Brainiac story Superman is
trapped in the city powerless and
branded an outlaw because of a
misunderstanding
so he and Jimmy Olsen create superhero
personas inspired by Batman and Robin
they need their vigilante names so
Superman uses the names of his friends
to pet Birds
Nightwing and flame bird Superman took
the name Nightwing and Jimmy Olsen took
the name flame bird they teamed up with
Batman and Robin and it was still the
Dick Grayson version of Robin at the
time and then later when it came time
for Robin to move out on his own and
pick a more adult superhero persona he
remembered that adventure and chose the
name Nightwing to honor Batman and
Superman you've all seen the crisis on
Infinite Earths flash DC TV trailers
that have been posting we just found out
about Tom Welling Superman coming back
for that
after the comic book crisis storyline
Superman had no memory of ever being the
Nightwing character but he did remember
an urban legend from Krypton about a
vigilante named Nightwing he told that
story to Dick Grayson who was then
inspired by that legend and that's how
he then took the Nightwing name so a
couple different versions of the origin
story obviously the Titans TV show
version is gonna be a little bit
different too we haven't gotten Superboy
on the TV show yet but they tend to
introduce the Justice League characters
corresponding with their Teen Titans
counterparts like they introduce some
Wonder Woman stuff last season when they
introduced on a Troy for the first time
so when they introduced the Conner Kent
Superboy this season it makes sense that
eventually we'll see some sort of
Superman can do I believe Conner Kent is
debuting somewhere around the middle of
the season so that's probably when you
start to see Dick Grayson inspired to
take the Nightwing name and then get the
Nightwing costume so we've still got a
little while before we see them running
around in it but this is what it's going
to look like and I'm actually really
happy based on these blurry potato cell
phone picks but everybody post your
reactions in the comments below what do
you think about them going with the
rebirth Nightwing design and obviously
this is a more tactical version of that
suit you may remember the Nightwing web
series from a couple years ago from
Danny
Shepard and his friends they did a great
job with that but this is the first
official live action version of
Nightwing that we've seen from DC and
Warner Brothers still pretending to be
the detective well yes you are my
guardian angel right guardian angel I
guess you could say that look I
appreciate what you did for me at the
club really but I had this covered as
you can see they went for red hood a
much more adult version of Jason Todd I
think it's gonna be a while before we
actually get to red hood on the Titans
TV show because first they gotta play at
this Teen Titans Judas contract arc
which seems like it's gonna spill unto
Titan season 3 then they have to kill
off Jason Todd he has to stay in the
ground for at least a little while or
someone can steal the body and then
either use a Lazarus Pit if they want to
do racial güell in the Lazarus pits on
Titans or if they want to do a slightly
different method with someone else
brainwashing him and turning him into a
killing machine but like I said because
it seems like they're trying to be his
comic book accurate as possible with all
this stuff
I think that they would actually go for
a more authentic Red Hood origin story
when they eventually do that but
obviously this version of the character
is so much younger so it'll have to be a
younger version of Jason Todd when he
eventually debuts on the show in a
future season I'll do more Titans
easter-egg videos once we get more big
reveals like this but leave all your
requests in the comments below they'll
be more crisis on Infinite Earths flash
arrow DC TV trailers coming up -
congratulations Glen Waldrop you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my flash season
6 trailer at Tom Welling Superman
returning and click here for that brand
new Rick and Morty season 4 trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you